SABOTAGE, THAT IS THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
PEOPLE OFTEN ASK ME "HOW DO YOU
PUT UP WITH ALL OF THESE
LIBERALS WHO COME ON YOUR SHOW?"
THEY ARE VICIOUS AND INTOLERANT
AND THEY ARE SO ROOTED IN THE
AGE OF TRUMP.
I SAY THAT'S TRUE, FAR TOO MANY
OF OUR DEMOCRAT FRIENDS HAVE
DRIVEN OFF THE DEEP END.
THEY SPEND THEIR DAYS AND
GNASHING THEIR TEETH AND
SPITTING BILE INTO A HEADWIND,
EVERY DAY SINKING FURTHER INTO A
PIT OF POLITICAL PSYCHOSIS.
THEY ARE OBSESSED WITH TRUMP,
MUTTERING ABOUT MUELLER,
DON, JR., RUSSIA, AND BILL BARR.
>> I'M RECOMMENDING THAT WE
IMPEACH ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL
BARR.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAVING
OBSTRUCTED THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT INVESTIGATION, NOT
OBSTRUCTING CONGRESS DOES ADD
WEIGHT TO IMPEACHMENT.
>> IF YOU ARE TOLD YOU MUST
TESTIFY WE WILL BACK THAT UP AND
WE WILL USE ANY AND ALL POWER IN
OUR COMMITTEE, WHETHER IT'S
FINES OR POSSIBLE INCARCERATION.
>> Laura: IF ONLY THEY SPENT
AS MUCH TIME THINKING ABOUT WHY
THE COUNTRY ELECTED TRUMP IN THE
FIRST PLACE, OR MAY BE HEAVEN
FORBID PUSHING POLICIES THAT
ACTUALLY APPEAL TO WORKING-CLASS
AMERICANS.
MAYBE THEN THEY WOULDN'T BE SO
ANGRY.
OR MAYBE THEY WOULDN'T BE SEEING
THEIR 2020 DARLINGS SCRAMBLING
FOR RELEVANCE ALREADY NEEDING TO
REINVENT THEMSELVES.
>> WOULD YOU SAY THAT WAS A
MISTAKE BEING ON THE COVER OF
"VANITY FAIR"?
>> I THINK IT REINFORCES THAT
PERCEPTION OF PRIVILEGE.
THAT HEADLINE THAT SAID I WAS
BORN TO BE IN THIS, NO ONE IS
BORN TO BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, LEAST
OF ALL ME.
>> Laura: PROFOUND.
FOR A WHILE, DEMOCRATS WERE
BULLISH ON 2020, RIGHT AFTER THE
MIDTERMS.
THEY WERE CONVINCED THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS DESTINED FOR
JIMMY CARTER OR GEORGE W. BUSH
TERRITORY, THE ISLAND OF ONE
TERM PRESIDENT'S.
>> REPUBLICANS LOST WOMEN,
MINORITIES, AND THE SUBURBAN
VOTERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY, THAT
SHOULD WORRY EVERY REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE IN 2020.
>> IF HE'S GOING TO GET
REELECTED HE HAS SOME WORK TO D
DO.
>> HE SAW HIS NATIONAL BASIS
SHRINK LAST NIGHT.
>> IT'S A WARNING.
>> Laura: THAT WAS THEN AND
THIS IS NOW.
SPEND 5 MINUTES ON SOCIAL MEDIA
AND YOU CAN READ COMMENTS BY
LIBERALS, YOU CAN DISCOVER THEY
ARE NOT SO SURE ANY LONGER.
THEY SEE A STRONG ECONOMY AND
TRUMPS STEADY OR GROWING
APPROVAL NUMBERS AND THEY FEEL
LET DOWN BY THE MUELLER REPORT
AND THEY ARE DISSATISFIED BY
THEIR OWN PARTY LEADERSHIP --
THEY ARE UNSURE WHERE TO TURN
NOW.
MORE CITIZENS TODAY FEEL
CONFIDENT AND OPTIMISTIC ABOUT
THE FUTURE WHICH PUTS DEMOCRATS
IN AN ELECTION-YEAR BOX.
>> HOW MANY OF YOU FEEL
CONFIDENT TODAY THAT A DEMOCRAT
WILL WIN IN 2020?
[RINGING]
>> FEW POLICIES THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE ACTUALLY FLOATED HAVE
FLOPPED.
THE GREEN NEW DEAL IS A NEW TAX
AND MEDICARE FOR ALL, IT'S
ANOTHER FANTASY FREEBIE.
WHEN NONE OF THAT SEEMS TO
EXCITE FOLKS, DEMOCRATS DO THE
LAZY AND EASY THING, THEY
RETURNED TO THE RED SCARE.
>> EFFORTS WILL ACCELERATE GOING
FORWARD INTO 2020, RUSSIA WILL
PLAY A ROLE AGAIN.
THEY WILL TRY TO PUT THEIR THUMB
ON THE SCALE.
IF WE ARE GOING TO PROTECT THE
BALLOT BOX IN 2020 FROM ANOTHER
ATTACK, THE PUBLIC AND THE
NATION'S LEADERS SHOULD KNOW WHO
WORKED WITH THE RUSSIANS.
>> WE HAVE ANOTHER PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION COMING UP IN THIS
PRESIDENT HAS EVERY REASON NOT
TO PROTECT THAT ELECTION.
>> Laura: RAMBLIN JOE BIDEN
ALWAYS LATE TO THE GAME, HE WAS
PLAYING CATCH UP TO THOSE GUYS
TODAY UP IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
>> HE'S AN ILLEGITIMATE
PRESIDENT IN MY MIND AND MY
BIGGEST FEAR IS HE'S GOING TO DO
IT AGAIN WITH THE HELP OF HIS
BEST PAL AND WE ARE GOING TO BE
STUCK FOR SIX MORE YEARS AND
THAT IS TERRIFYING.
>> YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AND
NOW THEY HAVE AN INVESTIGATION
OF THE INVESTIGATORS WHO ARE
INVESTIGATING WHETHER OR NOT
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND THE RUSSIANS
ENGAGED TRYING TO AFFECT OUR
ELECTION, GIVE ME A BREAK.
>> Laura: LET ME REMIND YOU,
THAT WAS JOE BIDEN AT HIS
SHARPEST AROUND LUNCHTIME.
AND THAT IS THEIR FRONT RUNNER.
NO WONDER TRUMP SEEMED GIDDY
TODAY.
>> I'M LOOKING AT THE
COMPETITION, YOU START TO DREAM
ABOUT COMPETITION LIKE THAT BUT
WHO KNOWS?
350 MILLION PEOPLE AND THAT'S
THE BEST WE CAN DO.
EVEN AS DEMOCRATS, I COULD PICK
BETTER THAN THAT.
>> Laura: HE COULD HAVE BEEN A
STAND-UP COMEDIAN, I'M SORRY,
MOVE OVER DON RICKLES, HE'S SO
FUNNY.
POLITICS ABOUT TRUMP IS SOMEDAY
GOING TO BE ABOUT TRUMP.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HEAR ONE
PEEP OF ELECTION INTERFERENCE
EVER AGAIN BUT AS THE DOOMSDAY
SCENARIO COMES TO PASS, THEY
HAVE TO BLAME RUSSIA NOW OR FAKE
NEWS OR SOMETHING, ANYTHING FOR
THAT VICTORY.
THIS STRATEGY IS SUPPORTED BY
SOCIAL MEDIA GIANTS RIGHT NOW,
BY THINGS LIKE FACEBOOK THAT ARE
SYSTEMATICALLY DEEP PLATFORM AND
CONSERVATIVE VOICES.
THE PLAN IS TO DELEGITIMIZE ANY
INSTITUTION OR ANY INDIVIDUAL
THAT GETS IN THE WAY OF
DEFEATING TRUMP IN 2020.
IN THE END, DEMOCRATS ARE MAKING
A BIG MISTAKE.
THINK ABOUT THIS, AFTER USING
THE DEEP STATE TO SPY ON TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN, THEN THE MUELLER
PROBE, ALL THE SUBPOENAS AND
THREATS OF SUBPOENAS, THREATS OF
IMPEACHMENT, WHAT HAVE THEY
REALLY ACHIEVED.
>> WE ARE NOW LEARNING THAT HE
HAS TAPPED A TOP FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR IN CONNECTICUT.
>> HE'S GOING TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS.
>> LOOK AT HIGH-LEVEL
HIGH-PROFILE ABUSES.
>> I WOULD BE QUITE WORRIED.
>> Laura: OOPS, WHAT DID THEY
GET?
THEY GET JOHN DURHAM.
WE FINALLY HAVE A SERIOUS MAN
DOING THE SERIOUS PROBE OF REAL
GOVERNMENT CORRUPTION AND LAST
NIGHT WE LEARNED THAT BARR IS
COORDINATING WITH THE CIA AND
DNI, THEY WON'T NEED A PHONY